هناك رهانات هائلة ولكن هناك
لا سياسة
حتى يخسر حملته منذ أ
لا سياسة لذلك سوف نختار
بين إيمانويل في ماكيز أو الماكريل
أو إيمانويل لذلك الاختيار هنا هو
أنا في أعماقي كل نفس هناك
البعض مثل إيريك زمور الذي يذهب
تسمح حقًا بقول كل شيء
التي يفكرون بها بدون أي مرشح
لم يغير شيئا
أعتقد أن جان لوك ميلينشون نحن
يدافع ولكن بالمناسبة عندما يمر
لن يتغير سواء لذلك لا أنا
يميل أكثر إلى القول إن الأم لديه
حظ أفضل مع ميلينشون ربما
أنا عادل ومن يصوت
لن أخبرك حقًا والآن
ولكن هنا عندما يكون لدي تحيزي
وهو جيد
ميؤوس منه يجعلني لا يوجد
الحملة ولا سيما المناقشة و
إنه عار لأنه صحيح
أنه لا يزال من المهم
لتكون قادرًا أخيرًا على الدفاع عن الديمقراطية
لا ندرك ذلك طالما نحن
أنا حقا أجد صعوبة في الدخول
الفائدة لأن بالفعل المرشحين
لدي انطباع بأنهم يسمونه
عرض أكثر من الواقع
لذلك لهذا السبب أنا
لا تتكئ ولكن سأذهب على أي حال
التصويت لأنه مهم للغاية
هو أن هناك الكثير من المتطرفين
[موسيقى]